the foreign office minister with us
Jillian Keegan good morning you're
reminded that you were listening to what
he had to say yes yes well it's quite
obviously a worrying escalation
particularly the the last uh comments
there but uh and rather a rewriting of
History I think as well in terms of uh
what's happening in Ukraine so let me be
clear these are Putin's lies so he's
continuing to
um to completely misrepresent what's
happened in Ukraine it's an illegal war
in Ukraine it's Russia's a legal war in
Ukraine and of course we will still
stand by Ukraine as will all of all of
our NATO allies but yes some of the
language there was quite concerning at
the end and obviously we would Edge for
calm our Gravely should we take his
threat that he's not bluffing about the
potential to use nuclear weapons well
clearly you know it's something that we
should take very seriously because you
know we're not in control I'm not sure
he's in control either really I mean
this is obviously an escalation and of
course to the Russian people now who
will be conscripted into this into this
wall and it's hard to know what's going
on in Russia as well obviously they
don't have a free media like we can talk
freely here
um so that's that's also uh also
difficult but we've been very clear all
along and in fact uh the speech that the
Prime Minister will give today is going
to double down and say we will
absolutely continue to support Ukraine
and we will invest well we've already
put 2.3 billion pounds to support in the
military aid in Ukraine and other Aid in
Ukraine and we'll do the same next year
to continue what's our message what's
the government's message to the people
of Ukraine this morning and also to the
people of Russia well the people of
Ukraine um you know it's it's the same
message we're there we're by your side
we will help as as much as we possibly
can they're incredibly Brave and of
course we've also seen that they've made
some significant progress in the last
couple of weeks and a few days indeed as
well which is probably prompted this
speech to the to the Russian people look
beyond your own media it's very very
clear the whole global population is
very clear what's going on in Ukraine we
can all see what's going on in Ukraine
you know that there's lots and lots of
footage and in fact in isium we've now
seen some
um some war crimes some some evidence of
war crimes which is also why we've set
up the atrocity crimes Advisory Group to
try and make sure that we can help to
make sure that we capture that so there
are definitely war crimes and evidence
of sexual violence as well I know that
we only have a truncated time with you
this morning obviously because of
listening to President Putin um why did
Liz trust feel the need to go to New
York she's you know she's having a
bilateral face-to-face talks with Biden
she could have had that here and there's
no trade deal on the table
oh no I mean there's lots of world
leaders in New York in fact pretty much
lots of people who came here to go to
Her Majesty's funeral
um pretty much all of them went uh on on
the plane there's lots of things to be
discussed there's lots of bilaterals
that will be taking place obviously one
with President Biden and she also will
be giving a speech which is an important
Forum in in
um foreign policy attempts to be able to
say look this is this is what we're
going to do and to show that leadership
on the global stage that we will be
there continually supporting Ukraine so
I think that is important and it's the
it's the place to do it and actually I
think possibly the timing of this speech
and the fact that the world leaders are
all there together is is probably the
right place to be right now exactly and
Sulkin because he wasn't invited the
funeral some might say I don't know um
talk to me about the cost of living
crisis briefly Before I Let You Go one
question on businesses getting support
from the first of October it's not very
far away yes and Fridays when we'll hear
more so that's not very far away as well
so uh you will know tomorrow today
you'll hear more on businesses and then
Friday you'll hear more uh from the
chancellor as well in terms of support
um I mean this is the first time
actually that there has been a support
for businesses on the energy crisis
um obviously there's been lots of
support for businesses during the past
couple of years with coronavirus but we
do recognize that there's lots of small
businesses who have been hit with
massive energy bills as well again as a
result of this war in in Ukraine you
know this has had massive impacts not as
big as it's had on the people of Ukraine
but certainly having a lot of impact on
people here and on businesses here and
of course we need to be there to support
them so we've already announced a big
package for people and there'll be a
similar package for uh six months I
think for businesses but then there'll
be more targeted support for specific
industries that are more vulnerable to
the increase in Energy prices okay and
the front page of the times this morning
suggesting that stamp duty is is going
to be reduced on Friday people are
exchanging on a house today should they
wait till Friday well they'll have to
wait and hear what the the chancellor
says on Friday so obviously I can't tell
people and you always get this when
you've got changes Etc but um what I
will say is that Friday will be
announced in pro-growth pro-business
really trying to really boost the growth
in our economy which obviously has
suffered from many of the shocks that
we've had with coronavirus and obviously
dealing with this war as well so now is
the time to really try and focus on that
and ensure that we're in good shape
really for the future